foul  rebound mcconaughey the hit ahead for  wara  and what a play by struce block the shot  without fouling hiro it counts  oh what a way to end a spectacular first  rule  allowing the heat to get some numbers on  the break gorgeous release nothing but  core for tyler hero  hiro fires it up in the buzzer  tyler  at the buzzer  graham from the top  and udonis on the glass  eats all-time leading role  oh that was over  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my hero  right-handed stuff  and deadman came over the top of the  foul  [Applause]  so eric spellstrik over tyler here as he  always does off the bench  hero  jam of the night  border junior squeezed it up hit the  side of the board  hiro with two seconds left in the half  lets it fly  yes  shall we it's tyler  at the buzzer got it away empty  critical minutes here to begin the  fourth autobio outside  hero  you said masterful correct right here  autobio right at the rim maxi came to  help  but  he wrote  showing off